[Music]
welcome to number 27 in this
worlds of speculative fiction series so
we're talking about Andre Norton who
ungodly amount of books at one time or
another you know you can see it in the
timeline I only put some of the books
that she wrote I don't like but you'll
see just how many there are in there so
welcome to those who are new and what we
usually do in this is we look at a
little bit of biography and the nature
of the world that that should create
there's a very clear coherent narrative
world running through the the witch
world and then I usually have some some
philosophical themes picked out and and
we usually end up veering off into
others as well we have people here
who've read the the book and some who
haven't so this is really good so the
the themes that I thought we would talk
about are rule and and wisdom and the
relationship between those in these
these books and then her models that she
sets out for relations between men and
women and there's a number of different
models running through these the
relationship between the what she
conceives of as magic and then
technology how these blend together in
this world and then how people who don't
actually have access to this wind up
making use of them in one way or another
and then identity you know we often say
like humming of age and her there's a
lot of coming-of-age themes in her
stories but I think it goes beyond the
typical young adult coming-of-age sort
of thing where it's more about
determining or discovering one's one's
identity so those are some interesting
themes that we can certainly talk about
others I gave a map and then a timeline
which might the map might be helpful
when we're talking about some of the
events in the book but before we do that
any more
yeah yep so yeah no no you want the hole
you want the time yeah so Norton is is
born in 1912 she dies in in the 90s and
she was pretty productive through most
of her life you notice that she actually
changes her name in part because she
felt that that would help her and
publishing she was writing at that time
what we would now call you know young
adult well yeah or actually juvenile two
novels and mostly for boys adventure
stuff so she changes her name to two
Andre Alice Norton I always you know I
guess I always know that she was a woman
now the first book of hers that I
encountered was in my uncle Hubert's
library the jargon party's way in the
middle of her her series I thought it
was pretty cool and it was already
listing her as a woman so so I just
thought Andre was a girl's name okay
from where she came from
I didn't know much about her biography
at that time she was born in Cleveland
and spent a good bit of time there you
noticed once she graduates from high
school she enrolls at Western Reserve
which is now Case Western Reserve she
wanted to be a history teacher and she
stressed the importance of studying
history throughout her life especially
when she would talk with other fiction
writers she gave a lot of advice over
the years but she had to drop out of
college in part because it was the
depression
so she winds up working in the cleveland
library she actually worked in almost
every single branch of the cleveland
library she got transferred around here
and there and then she started writing
and her first book is not a science
fiction or
see book it's it's an adventure book the
prince commands she doesn't actually
start writing anything recognizable as
you know her preferred genres until whoo
out of the horn in 1951 but in that time
she does a lot of interesting stuff she
becomes a special librarian in the
cataloging Department of the Library of
Congress so she goes down to Washington
DC and takes up residence there while
she's there she actually buys a
bookstore in Maryland and tries to make
a go of it but it never really takes off
and unfortunately goes out of business
after a while and then she goes back to
to Cleveland her first science fiction
story is published in this anthology
just called fantasy book and that's 1947
so you notice there's there's a good bit
of writing over a decade where she's not
writing in the genres that she's going
to be known for later on
she'll retire from the cleveland library
due to some health issues and then she
begins working as a reader for no
impress so this is kind of a cool job if
you're going to be writing stuff right
because you're looking at other people's
manuscripts and making contacts within
the industry and and notice she just
starts churning stuff out after that
some years she published four or five
books and some of these are the witch
world ones the ones that that fit into
that are the ones in bold so you can see
that there's kind of a progression going
on but she's got a lot of other series
that she's writing she becomes a
full-time writer in in 1958 after she's
already published in books she decides
okay this is what I'm gonna do full time
she she doesn't get a lot of awards
during her lifetime unfortunately given
how much impact she had she's nominated
for a Hugo but doesn't win the Hugo and
she's actually one of the founding
members of the saga
guild and we don't put 1965 there nobody
actually can give you a good date on
when saga formed it's very difficult to
find out but there's a few other kind of
trivial things that are that are
interesting Dungeons and Dragons I met
some of us probably played that at one
time or another Gary Gygax the guy who
created it you know here in Wisconsin he
invited her to play and his greyhawk
campaign so he was using her - yeah he
was very interested in having a big
author come in by now she's she's she's
very established so it's kind of an
honor for her but it's kind of an honor
for him she writes the very first of the
Dungeons & Dragons themed fantasy novels
and and then others you know follow in
her wake she starts getting you know
some some more formal recognition
getting a grandmaster award from the
science fiction and fantasy writers of
America moves around from from time to
time eventually settles in Murfreesboro
Tennessee and while she's there she
helps found this high Halleck library
high Halleck is one of her lands and she
founds his library which is actually in
her garage and it's a research library
for fantasy and science fiction writers
so as opposed to other you know
university research libraries which are
for more academic purposes this is this
is a library for people who want to
practice the craft and this is also why
she starts collaborating with so many
other authors if you I didn't put the
you know collaborators on here because I
wouldn't be able to fit them all in the
time line Mercedes Lackey Diana
are you learning more look 20 there's
like 20 yeah there's like 20 other
authors she coordinated she yeah now do
you know why she was so keen to do that
well she was she was getting older she
was getting older but she was mentoring
people she's this crazy well there was
that to me a writer she was there all
the other writers part of it though was
she realized that she needed to raise
money for this high Halleck library and
so she thought well if I collaborate
with people I can turn out more books
and make more royalties and I can put
that into the library so you know it's
it's all kind of fitting together right
the the mentoring the the promoting
other people's literature and
scholarship and and that went on for
quite a while she eventually dies in
2005 and she was still working hard to
change things in the industry even then
the by that time you know young adult
novels were really becoming big and she
was upset about the fact that within the
science fiction world most of the the
awards were for adult things so she
wanted to see some sort of award for
young adult novels and she pushed the
science fiction and fantasy writers of
America to do that and then she found
out about that as she was on her way
into the hospital for her last and fatal
illness that they'd actually approved
the award and had created it so she
lived quite an interesting life very
devoted to the to the craft constantly
stressing the need to not just you know
read other science fiction but to read
literature to read history to
incorporate these these elements into
one's work and she leaves behind a
massive legacy of books she's probably
they call her the grand-am of
science fiction and I guess that kind of
makes sense right so let's talk about
this actual world then what is the which
world
so if you notice it starts in 1963 and
if you've ever like seen the the copy
that I had I didn't unfortunately very
excited to return to the library the
artwork is not quite so nice as these
these newer ones it's actually kind of
strangely off-putting to see the the
cover art but that would that went along
with it and it includes you know these
sort of maps and everything in the first
one really takes place just in this part
of the map between s Karp Allison Gorman
and Kirsten and it's a world in which
you've got all these different peoples
much of which we don't learn about at
the start we only reveals bits and
pieces to us as she needs to so then the
first two novels were really just
confined to this part of the map and
she's slowly revealing these the back
histories of these these peoples and
places and then in the third and then
subsequent ones the ones that are in
this sort of omnibus volume the lost
lands that has three against the witch
world warlock of the witch world and
sorceress of the witch world which are
about these children so I caught them in
a moment we find out about the other
parts of the continent and she keeps on
getting you know bigger and bigger and
bigger in scope so I don't know if she
if she actually you might know this
weather or you might know whether she
planned that out at any point in time or
whether she just sort of added to it
over time I never saw anything anything
came that she plans so she's not a an
architect in that sorry
yeah yeah now that which world itself is
very old and there are these people
they're called the old race and there
are some of the original inhabitants of
the the land and then there's all these
other people who've come in at one point
or another and what's I guess you could
say what's unique to it is that there
are these gates that allow you to move
from some other world into the which
world and the story begins with this guy
Simon tree Garth going through one of
these gates he's he's been at World War
two he was an Army officer he's there in
Germany after the war and he somehow
gets involved in the black market and
essentially you know kicked out and he's
running from the authorities and he
knows about this guy who can disappear
you the way that the guy can actually
disappear use by sending you to a
different world so he gets sent to the
which world and he winds up there with
his pistol and you know a few other
things and immediately finds himself in
this this territory of alisone and
there's a woman who's being pursued by
hounds and these horsemen who are trying
to track her down he intervenes as it
turns out he doesn't even really need to
because she's a witch and she calls
lightning down to kill the the pursuers
and they sort of take up together and
then the story really centers on this
place s carp where the the old race
lives and they're you know sort of other
their last legs that's the way they're
portrayed through through much of these
these early stories they they have women
in charge who are witches
they run the society and everybody else
in the world is lined up against them
and so Allison is is pressing on them
from the north Carsten is pushing them
from the south they have a few allies
here and there but there's also this
place
and Gorham is an island who brought in
an ally who then took advantage of them
and essentially colonized them and that
is the colder so the colder are a group
of humans who have a high level of
technology so much so that they can
dominate the minds of other people and
they take the people from warm and
essentially turn them into zombies
willing to fight for them so you're
placed in in the middle of the story
right sort of in media races as they say
and most of the first of the second book
is the story about how the people of s
carp including some of the main
characters are able to fight off these
these different invaders and win
themselves a breathing space in the
process
Simon winds up falling in love with this
this witch who won't even reveal her
name to him until the end because names
are our power J Leith I guess is how
it's pronounced and they eventually do
get get married and have have three kids
Oh Liam she the very beginning she calls
lightning down and kills off these these
dogs and horsemen so yeah he he knows it
and and he knows that she's part of the
sort of ruling class there and and he
and and other people are involved in
trying to fight off these various
enemies so the first the first two books
are about that and then we get the story
of their kids in the next three books
and they you know they end up leaving s
carp and going across these mountains so
that's kind of the the back story and
and you know what else should we say
about it's it's essentially at a
medieval level of Technology alright so
it's a fantasy
there is magic going on right
that the old race was the original race
on this planet yeah and which is
actually came through a gate oh okay
when the world does that motivations are
there came through a gate yeah at some
point in their history yeah and then
some are still coming here some are
still coming through and they you know
they realize in their ancient history
they came through from someplace else
they're not original to this world yeah
so that would you know I was struggling
to think about what the usually I'd
turned into five philosophical themes
right and I only really came up with
four that I could sink my teeth into but
that that notion of we're not really the
first is kind of a cool idea and you
know Norton was very interested in not
just history but also ethnography so she
was reading ethnographic studies of you
know Native American tribes or
Polynesian people's and she's
incorporating some of this ideas into
that and if you think about how how hit
in history we've portrayed you know
original inhabitants we call it you know
indigenous peoples right it often turns
out to be wrong you know you think about
Europeans right in European identity
right now the people that we know is the
indo-europeans weren't the first people
in Europe the Basques are about all
that's left of that original group of
people who are you know pushed out
absorbed colonized and then you know
then then everyone can forget and say ah
we've always been here the SU you know I
remember reading this this classic
ethnographic study about the you know
the SU they started out essentially in
the woodland area not not that far from
here got pushed out onto the plains by
other tribes who are more successful in
warfare against them and within about
you know 20 generations forgot entirely
that they had ever lived any
and developed all sorts of origin
stories about how they'd always lived on
the plains always hunted the Buffaloes
but it was really an adaptive behavior
so I guess you could say that Norton is
is playing around with that idea and you
know what's what always happens when you
bring this up it really takes people off
right if you tell people well you're not
as original as you think people don't
like to hear that so their leads to
similar conflicts and her stories right
well they find out when you get into the
hi Howard novels you find out the old
ones had magic yeah different kind of
met they had magic and you see with the
cow pants there's a creature called the
kelpie odd dad I don't remember yeah
that's in the high hat yes you come
across them in that ellic novels and
they're original to this world but
they're a different kind of creature
yeah so you get into some different
things when you start getting into the
Dales and high Halleck and you run
across there are still ruins from the
old ones yeah still places to play you
should probably say something so the
high Halleck stuff is happening on a
different continent then then all of
this stuff here but it's still the same
world and so you know I mean how many
books in would that be into the series
where those River I mean so she's she's
she's slowly unpacking the world bit by
bit
35 yeah well a jar being hard it was at
74 I think that was in that's why yeah
it was a very first one I read well
actually in the three original which
world trilogy yeah
the third one is in hi house no it's in
it's an escort that's across the
mountains
yeah the year the universe so in the
same year she's actually like starting
divergent yeah yeah so I start early so
I mean that do we want to explore that
theme any any further this like you're
not really the originals or should we
move on to another aspect of the world
that she's creating like the men and
women thing was it harder for people to
take in the concept of not being the
originals or not being the original
culture what would be the distinction
there well I'm thinking in terms of
belief systems there are religions
belief systems people debate what was
the first you know in terms of it you
mean in terms of religions yeah in terms
of religions we were the we were the
first with this or you here with you
know cross yeah even with performing
with them sorry they're always we're
gonna get back to the beginning because
yeah yeah yeah that's quite true I mean
the the distinction that you're making
between original being the original
culture and then being the original
inhabitants so that I mean you could be
the original inhabitants but take on
somebody else's cultures what you're
saying I mean that does happen with most
of the indigenous peoples right there
most people who are Christian Jewish or
Islamic yeah they're not the first
bottle with - yes mystic ization yeah
they would not be happy but they're not
you know there was a monotheistic
restaurant is it oh yeah yeah I mean the
notion so Harry place you know a lot of
the angelology I mean it comes into
Judaism precisely because the Persians
were the ones who brought them out of
the Babylonian captivity there's a lot
the urgency right Judaism is the first
monotheistic religion oh yeah yeah it's
not yeah I think and the issue culture
yeah the issue of it is that when you
bring it up it'll provoke such anger and
here's the interesting thing I mean I
think for a lot of people originality
and truth wind up being fused together
and it could be that maybe we don't want
the original thing maybe we want the
more developed final thing rather than
the original completely different homage
you know I think it didn't L say
what does it start so the D and I yeah
did someone else even but whatever all
of this it just threw a lot of the
religious world into a tip because you
know yeah you know they thought the hand
it all figured out but when something
puts a kink in there they get
really very upset and all because then
their idea of what is truth has now been
you know has been challenged and for
some people with with very narrow
thinking that's very hard yeah so we see
that reflected here in before for
example that with the witches right so
the witches themselves are a very
conservative institution in in this
society of
esta carp they and they're unable to
sort of listen to anybody anybody who's
got something new to propose so Simon
and yeah jail a--the so they think it
married right and and the witches are
actually supposed to lose their power
when they lose their virginity so she
doesn't lose her power and he also has
some magical power which men aren't
supposed to have it all their kids wind
up with with power as well they have two
boys and one girl the witches trying to
take the girl and and you know sort of
force her into this this training I
guess you would call it our discipline
of being a witch of their sort and it's
not it's not a very good fit we can see
right she actually ends up becoming
something different by the end of her
storyline she becomes she's using a
different kind of magic she she becomes
a sorceress but they they have a very
rigid conception of things and sort of
many of the other people so we should we
should talk about about gender though
the witches themselves it's a
matriarchal society
they've do magic men don't do magic they
run the show not all women actually have
the the gift just the certain ones and
then they are they're trained in it and
and it's a trade off they can't
reproduce unless they give up their
power and they do need to reproduce in
order to have more with power so there's
there's a bit of a question about how
you actually do that there's another
culture that's almost diametrically
opposed to them these falconers who are
allies to to ask carp and the witches in
a certain respect these are all guys who
have the
yeah and what would you that what would
you say about the relation to the
Falcons it's not telepathic as such but
they're very they're very attached
they're birds yeah they communicate with
the birds mentally over a distance over
distances yeah so linked yeah and the
birds do incredible things these guys
it's it's a complete Brotherhood no
women at all involved they they have
villages of women that they go to just
for the the purpose of having sex and
making kids and then they take the male
kids and leave the females behind and we
don't really know much about the females
oh yeah yeah you're right okay yeah the
Amazons which would take mates and they
would only take the female children and
then induct them into their society so
you have two similar societies in a way
one matriarchal one and completely
patriarchal they just trust each other
but they're they're both older so
they're willing to fight against the the
other younger cultures who threatened to
sort of swap them Kirsten to the south
what we see being depicted there it's a
very male-dominated society but it's you
know much more in terms of you know
women being concubines or being used as
chips in bargaining for marriage one of
the characters who we get in there one
of the really well developed at least of
the first book characters is Royce
this woman who may in fact some people
theorized that that she was you know
going to a different author george RR
martin that Brienne of Tarth
may be modeled after voice yeah I think
that's plausible so Lewis is a an
unattractive tall thin very manly woman
who it happens to be unfortunately a
local
princess well not quite princess right
board yeah I forget exactly what the
it's not it's not a Duchy it's it's
something a little bit smaller than that
right marrying her gives them control
exactly yeah so she's she's being used
by her stepfather to try to solidify an
alliance and she really you know she's
done into that she likes doing you know
stuff with fighting and sailing and and
all that and she's been sort of pushed
into this you need to act like a lady
thing and she ends up decided to run
away and what she does is she dresses
like a man at arms and at that time
there's actually a witch jail if who's
prisoner there and so she frees her and
and takes her and she becomes part of
that you could say the the unit fighting
for asked carp and then she meets she's
still traveling incognito as a hey and
she meets what was his name Oh chorus
chorus is is one of the you know
interestingly another thing one critic
point of course is one of the first
really well depicted dwarf characters I
mean we have Gimli you know and people
like that and Tolkien stuff but he's got
a giant head and sort of deform body but
he's a very tough guy fights with an axe
and and is able to command man he's from
Gorham he had to leave
his ancestral home before it was taken
over and he fights as well and along the
way these two fight together and you
know come to appreciate each other let's
say and then fall in love with each
other
shortly after she reveals she's a woman
there's no there's no yeah yeah but you
know so what you see here is Norton is
very willing to play with male and
female roles in ways that many people
writing in her time were not willing to
do she doesn't like to depict sex as a
matter of fact that was one of the
things one of her collaborators brought
up that he this person almost didn't get
to collaborate because some of the books
they'd written had too many juicy scenes
of them so Norton he had to be you know
a sweet nice wage but assured that there
wouldn't be any you know gratuitous sex
scenes in there but she's very good at
depicting love relationships developing
over time she's very you know interested
and conscious about this and it is one
of the things that I found so she
channels reverses gender roles at times
to Simon the the main character the guy
who comes in from from outside he is the
one who kind of bumps around and is you
know quite emotional and sometimes
actually gets a little weepy from
tankmen I'm and the thing in the first
two books about the relationship and
Jahlil is much more practical
she gets things done you know it's not
that they don't love each other but
she's in some respects originally better
it's not that she's unemotional either
she's got a better handle on her
emotions than he does what's up or
germane she was almost
in command the riches yeah she was a
position of authority yeah but he was
too long before she met him but he was
too I mean he was he was the army
officer he well the top everything
talked about scale right because I mean
think about the US military forces in
Europe you know I mean million people
right so you don't know you know I don't
think SRP even he has remotely close to
that population I mean if he was a
captain even if he would have commanded
at least 120 men I forget I think he was
a captain right I'm just thinking she
was right next to the top yeah that's
true
who's leading the country yeah and so
she was used to making those kinds of
decisions and being around those kinds
of decisions
you know leading the army working with
chorus so you have to lead the army
so she was used to that kind of
authority making alliances taking
alliances yeah doing the spine is she
she's in Carson cuz she was spying true
capabilities allow either character to
step outside of his or her prescribed or
prescribe gender roles because they
aren't sacrificing anything in the
relationship right if both are competent
and have military minds and have
efficiency oh yeah so he doesn't have to
be the sole well or Breanna party and
what's his name no I was thinking about
the other yeah the guy with the beard
Thormann be more fluid with that right
because there's not the sense that if
one if one goes more toward an emotional
vendor more do you know the opposite
that somehow there's a deficit in their
relationship there wouldn't be one
that's yeah that's it I think that works
here you know that the other thing is we
do have a triad - right with two
brothers and one sister as well yeah and
and they're they're sort of stuck at
birth because jail if decides actually
wrote this down yeah she she sets sort
of a vocation on them warrior sage which
says 3:1
I will this each a gift together one in
great apart far less so they're supposed
to have that kind of reciprocity working
together as well and then they don't do
as well
apart from each other whether well
they're separated they they actually
have a so that is like an almost like a
telepathic bond right with between the
three of them where they're able to call
to each other so let's talk about rule
that Judith is is part of the ruling
class until she loses her power and then
she is kind of on the outs with the
wishes the witches are willing to give
men some power you're sort of delegating
it to them to fight to lead the troops
but they they mostly keep power to
themselves and they have a lot of power
not
in terms of political power but in terms
of magic they they actually at one point
raised these these mountains up to
destroy an invading army and to cut off
Karsten from them and sort of settle
that issue one time for all so that's a
lot of power now what you can answer the
question not just who has power but who
should empower who should rule and this
is a question of political philosophy
what is the basis for getting to be in
charge this is something that we you
know work through every generation you
know who's supposed to benefit from it
you know some of the characters in this
clearly are out for power but they're
they're they're they're not saying well
I should be in charge because it's gonna
be better for everybody if I'm in charge
it's more like well I deserve power or I
can take the power so therefore you
better listen to me we do have some
other characters who are not like that
Simon for example or chorus but most of
them seem to be you know competing for
power so what what are the sort of
claims that somebody could or should
make to justify being given authority so
is she the only witch that doesn't lose
power well they they believe who will
lose power and so they do it's really
she's separating she thinks she's lost
her power yeah and she discovers after
they've been married just a very short
time that she does still have power it's
taking a different twist slightly
different but she still has power yeah
they have a the the witches have a gem
that they use sort of to Fergus but it
turns out that you don't actually need
it and it's because yeah it's because
she's with assignment so son most of the
men in that world don't have the power
right they don't have the magical
ability what Simon does it turns out and
this has actually been useful for him in
the earth world where he could like you
know sort of predict where enemy troops
were gonna go but never really
understood why and so in a way he sort
of the catalyst for her rediscovering
that that she's not just you know an
ordinary housewife now she's actually
still still a movement I mean is there a
lot about oh she has a lot of strong
female yeah all of her books but to have
a male who isn't supposed to have a
woman who doesn't lose power after
coupling and transforms rather than
diminishes is sort of an interesting
commentary and lately it's about
feminism right yeah you find out that
you put the two of them together they
have a different power by the two of
them working together there's a
partner's as partners
so I mean then combine their thinking
combine their two powers and have
something else yes I mean if suddenly I
just think I'm on a book power and
gender I mean it is she influenced and
we can talk about different kinds of
feminism right so there's like well we
got to equalise everything sort of mary
wollstonecraft you know everybody's got
everyone should be brought up to the
same level sort of essentialism okay you
know well I mean this is coming out of
63 yeah yeah so I mean it's tough to say
because she's she's very literate right
so she she's a you know not only a
librarian but she's she's she's
selling books she's reviewing things
because presumably should have been
pretty well and when she was born
there's female science fiction writers
yeah it's really the butcher he has one
of the most luckiest like probably can
match her really today yeah Wow Mercedes
Lackey can probably match her today okay
if you look at her list yeah
when you jump rope power in this land
what I saw and I see it in other books
so you see it in the dark over series
beyond others a lot of medieval power
structures in Karsten it's a very
medieval power so yeah with the men
owning the land the men being in power
they're the royalty yeah and you see
that in the dales over hi Alec a lot
because the people who sell the deals
come from the mainland across the
refugees yeah and women are essentially
reduced to sort of like living our wives
and they take care of the house yeah
well but they're also used service
bargaining between them yeah baby
Alliance is that kind of thing yeah yes
start the webinar
the power is within the women because
they have power yeah cuz they have
magical power if they didn't have
magical power
they'd be like everybody else like
everybody else yeah in Amazon the power
structure is based on warriors yes but
in some ways they're very in norm
they're only that they're really human
but there's this technology oh yeah you
mean the colder people the colder yeah
yeah we should actually talk about that
because we've mentioned them a few times
so that this this group comes in from
another gate and these are the they call
themselves the colder and they start
taking over parts of the world so they
get brought in as allies by by gorm this
island and then they just take over the
whole place and they have they have much
greater technology they have like you
know planes I can bomb places they have
great you know weapons and then they
they take the dead or captives and turn
them to their purposes and it's through
kind of you know pretty difficult right
you know that sir
I almost imagined like a colander being
on somebody said the way it's described
with some wires coming out of it but but
they they have these things that are
that are placed on people's heads and
they tap into their brains and then they
can control them and they're they're
like zombies this is like way before
zombie literature and shows and stuff
like that but the way that they're
they're described is very similar to
what we see in the shows that people are
watching today and so they're trying to
figure out how do you stop these people
how can you break the control that they
have because they're relentless they
take over the culture and Carsten and
the only people that that can't be
controlled by them are these people the
old race everybody else can so that's
part of why colder is trying to wipe out
s carp we find out later on that that
there's still an open gate good yeah and
and there's some people left on the
other side and then they're they're
actually used to eventually destroy the
colder but that takes a long war against
them and you know they're you could say
that in a way the colder is almost like
an element of horror isn't it would you
say rather than a straight fantasy or
science fiction it's kind of its kind of
like
yeah I mean like the the notion of these
people can take you over and turn you
into a mindless drone who's going to
serve their evil purposes you know this
is the whole world that's part of it to
the east of what is that dirt tower it's
the only thing I can read on the firm
right yeah it's a little hard to make up
so those there's a whole bunch of place
names in escort those are those are the
things that are happening in these yeah
and so they actually that's worth
talking about as well so you know in in
the stories they keep talking about
north south and and west and nobody ever
talks about the east any why the hell
not it'd be like sort of like living
let's say you lived in Waukesha and you
near that you know Brookfield existed
and you know Wales in Delafield what's
that north of Waukesha Falls and then to
the south would be what like Mukwonago
now imagine you never thought about
Mukwonago you'd never go south yeah well
why the hell not right well because as
it turns out the witches in eschar that
whole civilization they came out of the
east and they they sort of established
or what would you call it sort of a
mental block right preserve preventing
that anybody from thinking about it was
it more so it was more of an exodus than
like a diaspora like they chose they
chose to leave yeah that's an
interesting distinction yeah yeah in an
exodus you're fleeing you don't know
exactly where you're going but you're
just trying to get the hell out of there
you might be fleeing persecution or
something like that yes Court has a lot
or over race yeah
location sites like Green Valley yeah
where you have remnants of your grace
you have sacred sites you have magical
sites if people who are at one time
connected with the race but the old race
in s carp has lost all memory of that
and you're saying this sort of a
selective amnesia yeah and the kids this
is part of the plot points in the third
novel the one who's the sage the the
middle brother he figures out that
there's something to the east and that
nobody else seems to be able to
understand he does this through like
reading texts and then he proposes let's
get out of s cart and we're gonna go
east because there's really nowhere else
to go so he says we'll go east and then
they'll never find us now how are they
able to break that block well their
father is he's from Earth so they don't
participate in that mental block in the
same way that everybody else does so
he's a sage there's another brother
there's a warrior is a warrior and then
the sister becomes the yeah she's
supposed to be a witch yeah and that's a
good that's a good place to talk about
another theme so magic you know we've
been bringing this up there's different
kinds of magic in the in this world a
lot of it you know people who've talked
about you know models for magic say that
that much of the magic in lost lands of
the witch world or in the witch world
stuff is is what you call low magic
where it's almost like a technology now
you got to know how to manipulate things
you have to use the right rules to get
things done rather than just have like
having like power that usually snap your
fingers and a fireball comes out you
actually have to like do things the
right way to make the fireball happen so
it is kind of like a technology that's
using forces that others can't perceive
and there's multiple ways to do this in
this world
have she had she would have the ability
to be a witch
with the gem and everything but instead
she chooses sorcery is a different kind
of power okay because her father is
Simon that her jameth she has an
entirely different kind of power does it
require the chilis study yeah and then
she does do that eventually but she'd
that the which is also trying to sort of
force her into their model of doing
things as well she rejects that or she's
well she's stuck with it until her
brothers get her out of there I think
that made and the only reason why
they're able to actually do that is
because the witches do that mountain
raising thing that requires so much
attention and power that it weakens
their their capacity yes so they these
are three like you know essentially like
you know teenagers and they all go east
but in terms of the question of magic
like the changes in their power to
structure are more consequence of their
birth than they are any sort of fighting
evolution in the way that this like the
society is being say that one more in
times of changes in whose powers oh the
changes in their statics the fact that
you know he's a sage and the others a
warrior and she's a sorceress sorceress
the reasons that those paths are
available to that where those becomes a
peasant take is because their situation
is a consequence of their birth because
they're important yes father from Earth
of which well I'm the father from Earth
is himself a warrior so he commands
troops in eschar it is there I mean in
her writings is there a lot about what
they then would have as children to have
powers that they would yeah yeah so this
theme of like shifting powers and
shifting magic from generation to
generation then where they're like you
know like the next generation is
surprised by some new mobility we're
like is it a constantly boring thing
yeah I'd say so probably because you see
it in the high Halleck stories yeah
where children are born out of a
relationship where someone from the old
blood marries a human yeah our breeds
with a human and then the children have
different powers being visible they're
different physically they're different
like there's one character who's a
prince who has who looks like a goat so
it's kind of a cool mythology I think
you can also say too that in each like
generation of the story cuz yeah okay
you can talk about like different the
first two novels are one generation the
the next three are another generation
they're not only like figuring out where
they fit in there also encountering so
much new stuff yeah
and and this is one of the things that
Norden is particularly good at is and
this isn't really a theme but it's
something worth pointing out how do you
take a world that you've already created
and bring something new into it like a
new culture new rules for things to go
and not screw up the general picture at
the same time I think a lot of ours are
able to pull that off very well we see
this in television shows all the time
right where we start out with like one
early conflict you know like the earth
men versus these people right and then
we find out that there's a larger world
that it's very tough to keep expanding
it in such a way that you don't ruin the
story and the process and it may be the
fact that you know there's there's a
good bit of time between these you know
sometimes a year sometimes several years
the kids are time to know although she's
read each other's stuff maybe doesn't
have that much time
plan it out I don't know the other thing
I'll say to stylistically and then
though those of you who have read it you
know tell me if I'm if I'm dead wrong on
this the books kind of feel like not
they're not unfinished in the sense of
like not polished writing they
definitely are well-written but each one
in like the first five books ends in
such a way they're like what it ends
here it's not the the you don't have a
complete resolution with with any of
them and they they're they go very quick
when you're reading them - yes I've
written to be a series
they're almost I was thinking about this
as when I was coming in they're almost
like they were written for pulp stuff
but she didn't write for pulp write some
of the authors that we looked at they
would write you know these these stories
and they have to be serialized this is
more like each one of them as a pulp
installment you know but a seventy
thousand word pulp install this rather
than like a six thousand word one and
then what do you guys think to you does
that make sense or am i dead dead wrong
on that or I think the one where its
strongest where that happens most
clearly is from which world do with the
truth because which world ends and the
hot the holder the holder is a threat
yeah and it's not resolved yeah they've
won one battle against one man you don't
know sound that chill the next book yeah
so that one clearly ends as if there's a
sequel coming that's true yeah that one
it's really clear I don't think in the
other books it's quite that way well I
mean once you tell the story one kid you
gotta tell the story in the next kid
right so I mean once you get to the
third and fourth maybe
you creasing it ends abruptly as an
unfinished or that is no no neither it
just it's not it's not unfinished but it
feels unfinished okay almost and then
those three legs aren't necessarily
resolved in the sequel they are well
they are they're always not they're not
only resolved but they managed to be
woven into larger story lungs which is
part of I think her her greatness every
book for another story no okay and they
do get into sort of like Batman like
conundrums where how could they possibly
you know yeah get free for this yeah and
I do and you know that the answers are
not implausible it's not sort of deus ex
machina you know something comes down
and just solves the problem for them so
one of the other themes I wanted to talk
about and I think it comes up with Simon
and and jellies but but even more so
with their kids is this notion about
figuring out who you are and I mentioned
that you know you can see each of the
three novels you know number three four
and five as being a coming-of-age story
in a sense but they're being they're
they're bigger than that each of these
these people already has a role and
they're figuring out where they they fit
into the the land and they they left and
make him back to and I came across an
interesting quote somebody had written
that in these which world series
for for Norton personal fulfillment
required accepting the individuals
contradictions whether they were sexual
racial or otherwise and then they use
this as an example that that you know
the females think falsely they have to
remain virginal to retain their power
but I thought there was a nice way to
talk about it as human beings we always
have contradictions you know we're not
we're not perfectly rational our lives
are kind of a mess they're always kind
of cobbling things and you know I think
about from the adolescents on where
we're always like redefining ourselves
one way to try to deal with it it could
just get rid of the contradictions and
you do that by saying okay this
contradicts this I have to make a
decision between these two and I'll
never talk about this again you know and
that's that's what the witches are doing
in this and that's what the falconers
have done in their society that's I
think what Carson is doing whenever
they're trying to evade and that's not
what Norton portrays or characters is
doing instead they integrate these
contradictory parts of themselves and
sometimes they do so like like you're
pointing out in terms of their
relationship so it's not just I can
integrate the contradictory parts of
myself but if I'm involved with you I
also can't I also try to integrate
what's you know what's tapped into you
you know our relationship and and I try
to integrate that with with what's going
on with me and and not not make the
contradictions go away but you sort of
take the you take the sting out of them
that way but isn't there a danger in the
process that you're homogenizing
diversity that you need well versity has
right Jeff become kinder addictions or
yeah ever but are they really just so
integral elements of diversity yeah that
we can't deal with right away yeah so we
call them a contradiction so integrating
isn't doing that well in deep meaning
yeah to an extent but if you there's a
risk of over integrating your organizing
things
now he has destroyed the diversity that
has a value what went through itself and
that's that's what like the witches you
know are doing in this they they make
that decision well everything's got to
be the way that we've had it for
generations that's one way to do it
right yeah there's there's there's a
definite danger and I think too you know
when you're talking about young people
they they don't really know what the
hell a they are you know I may think
about when we were young you know I know
things have turned out very very high
ever envisage well they might be like
and so I think this is a really this is
a theme that she deals with over and
over again not just in these books but
also in a number of her her other books
this how does the character figure out
where they fit in and the what you're
calling diversity I think is a good way
to talk about it
you know how do we probably bring these
together because if you're too diverse
right you can't function you have to
have some sort of Center some sort of
identity otherwise you just sort of you
just sort of floating or the parts
within unites each other you know can
you create different diverse worlds or
groupings that are not threatening to
you therefore the diversity can exist
outside of you and it's not threatening
no I mean you have a dama community yeah
yeah and communities based on some
commonality of values but doesn't mean
you have to destroy other you know
values that exist elsewhere outside of
you unless you feel threatened by them
if you're very confident
your own core identity don't you to
interact with cultures that challenge
you without feeling threatened you can
interact with cultures that are
different than yours without feeling
like you're going to be someone
assimilated into it or yeah you know
rundown being who you are yeah so we
have a few characters in these stories
who do exactly that
like the Simon guy right he can he's not
gonna fit in with the the Alice on
people but pretty much everybody else in
the story a lot over the colder people
but pretty much everybody he can kind of
relate to you know he can he can talk
their language and get along with them
in one way or another but most of the
other people in the story they're not
like that they they do have that
mentality of well you're from there so
gotta kill you know a lot of human
nature we see anyway you know it's like
we need to modernize it to keep it
simple so that it's what he'd expect and
if you're different
yeah you either have to assimilate you
know speak our language become like us
or else you're out and there's there's a
human tendency I think the simplify
things
yeah because easier manage if if few
more similar then if they're different
beyond this in this case you see it with
the witches here because the witches and
their power that's always been so any
girl who shows power must be trained and
be like us yeah and that's just how it
is that's it's a simple you have power
you're trained this way yeah that's who
that's if you if you that's right if you
think the power is gonna be different
that complicates things it's a question
of safety too I mean other side of
imagine
you're not safe sometimes I meet with
some people if they're not completely
certainly perceive it that way yeah yeah
I mean I guess the problem is that very
often you know we can take a lot more
diversity right then we originally think
that we we can and so we might shut it
down
precisely because of simplicity
reliability or you know sometimes we we
got to get things done right away too
we want things to be the same across
when we talk about standard operating
procedure right you see a Memphis banks
what we're talking about maybe at the
beginning that yeah truth people use
this idea of truth yeah because I got
the I got the longer standing truth
whatever is this so that's what I have a
better truth there for you come on be
like I mean yeah I guess yeah yeah well
interestingly so the colder these people
who are like you know very
technologically advanced but kind of
soulless and then turning everybody else
into their slaves controlled mentally
they are the epitome of that in this
world they're they're trying to take
over everybody and sort of make make
them all be one big I can't say happy
family but one day everybody's on the
same page
kind of kind of community and so they're
they're portrayed as being the bowls
tomorrow those lines but then the
witches are like that too and certainly
even you know those those Hawk guys are
like that as well they all have their
each of the cultures has a tendency to
what you're calling homogenizing you
know in these stories and the question
is like who's going to who's going to be
the top homogenous
you know I mean the one group that at
present tests you know the one group
like time goes on
yeah change so there is one group who
who I would say is more respectful of
diversity and that's the ones that are
modeled after the Vikings the salt carp
yeah they are Rovers you know they they
take their their their whole families on
their other ships and sail around and
sometimes we read people sometimes
engage in trade you know and they the
way they're portrayed everybody gets to
sort of decide for themselves how
they're going to be there is their local
leaders but those are people who don't
they're not leaders because of law or
having magic it's they can get people to
recognize you have more exposure
different cultures more exposure to
different ways of looking at things that
people always standing yeah there's two
there's two ways to do that I remember
you know when I was in the Army we have
a t-shirt that said join the army travel
the world meet strange and interesting
people and kill them you know somebody
could diversity you know
I'm gonna rack up a new set of trophies
or something but let the via right in
the in general travel travel widens our
horizons I'm a major piece of the rich
world ties in with a bunch of other
world builders okay is the gates o the
concept of parallel universes yeah we
had it with more [ __ ] yeah you see it
with one after another I just came
across a new series that has it the
Brian Empire series by lawhead MJ which
has the same concept of you've got
multiple worlds yeah you've got that
place in between the worlds like a
forest with pools and stuff gates
between worlds extra dimensional I mean
the the there's I guess two ways in
which it gets done right you've got like
that well I'm gonna jump through gates
myself you know you've got like the
single traveller or maybe a band of
people and everybody else more or less
stays in the same place in the universe
or you've got like whole migrations of
people which is what's happening in
because everybody is trying to migrate
from someplace else
yeah pretty much but when you have whole
peoples now you got to figure out well
who's gonna live where and who's gonna
colonize who
to get along you know if it's just like
travelers almost like tourists right
touristing different worlds then they're
not that big of a deal maybe they'll
bring a disease or well you've got the
individual assignment yeah then you've
got well they don't get well so Simon at
the very beginning yeah it's it's
actually the siege perilous of
our theory of legend turns out it's an
actual seat that you sit on and at the
right time of the day it transports some
areas some are much bigger - well most
people just happen upon them although in
which world they know where some of the
games are yeah the colder used their
game
and they they like put some people on
one side to guard it and they actually
end up leaving them there which really
takes them off and then you know they're
constantly putting mattad material
through so it's a very organized way of
using the gate yeah
others they they find a gate and there
they're trying to escape what is their
world so they use the gate as an escape
people are just in it open a wardrobe in
and up it very now they know what's
happening well this book but there's a
lot of this sort of thing out there in
yeah television and movies a lot - and
someday they'll just be like I've seen
pursuit of a sudden kaput ready yikes I
put in another world
yeah and there's a lot of this Tessa
wrecking things stuff going on that's a
big thing and opening portals and
opening for other worlds there's a lot
of that in like a lot of the marbles
some of the horror stuff too you know
open up the gate to the wrong place and
you let the wrong thing in stranger
things
oh that's fun yeah I mean I suppose in a
way it's there are no thing it's not in
this story yeah this framework yeah they
know these gates know it depends on the
culture I mean this is a world of many
cultures some are very low-level
barbaric they you know so they be the
ones to kind of like Bill and Ted's
Excellent Adventure themselves into
something right like suddenly they're
there well they don't have bungling yeah
I guess yeah yeah yeah or or they came
through at one time like generations ago
and then they forgot that they were came
through there yeah you know or
communities create their kids Stonehenge
and others stone monuments that well
that's that's what the quarter do in the
second book yeah they create a date so
he can get back to their original world
yeah
and different different world builders
do it differently you can have gates
where there's a there's a system to get
you where you want to go but if you take
the wrong step if you have a place how
you going to slow you end up in a
different place
it's a formulaic other places it's just
in this one Simon Trebek is told in the
very first book to sit on the siege
perilous and it will take him to a world
that suits him that's right yeah I
forgot about that he will vote so they
can go to multiple places so to multiple
places and acknowledges that there are
multiple places yeah but says he's told
it will take him to a world that suits
him so it puts him in a world where a
warrior you know put in the place
well we should probably wrap up so very
stimulating discussion next time we're
doing Arthur Clark
[Music]